سنوات قليله تفصل روني عن ترك هذه المكنسه
التي ضلت مصدر رزقه لاعوام طويله لكن فكره
التقاعد بدات تثير قلقه لاسيما في ظل
المعاناه التي يعيشها كثير من اصحاب
المعاشات في البلاد
قدرتهم على التدفئه بسبب غلاء فواتير
الغاز والكهرباء وهذا عار لكن هذه هي
الحال التي وصلنا اليها في بلادنا
نسبه التضخم التي فاقت 11 في المئه قضمت
جزءا كبيرا من معاشات المتقاعدين ما دفع
اكثر من 170000 منهم الى العوده للعمل في
الربع الثاني من العام الجاري ليقفز عدد
العاملين من هذه الفئه الى مليون ونصف
مليون
صلي بنك الطعام هذا شرقي لندن تكشف عمق
الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها البلاد
فقد اصبح حمص البريطانيين الذين يرتدون
هذه الجمعيات من اصحاب الوظائف الذين لم
تعد اجرهم تكفي للتدفئه والطعام
هم من الموظفين ولكن العدد اكبر بكثير
بالنسبه الينا نساعد الناس في الحصول على
ما قيمته 25 جنيها من الطعام وهو ما يوفر
لهم المال
على الحكومه ان تتحمل مسؤوليه اكبر في
توفير حق الوصول الى الطعام لمواطنها
على هذا الحق قبل 50 عاما كان يستهدف
الدول الافريقيه وليس واحده من اغنى دول
العالم فمن حق الناس الوصول الى الغذاء
تحديدا الصحي لانه سيخفف التكلفه على قطاع
الصحه
يعترف وزير الخزانه البريطاني بان بلاده
دخلت في مرحله ركود لكن تبقى مساله ما اذا
كانت خطته الماليه الجديده قادره على
انتشال البلاد من ازماتها الخانقه
اصبح بعضهم عاجزا عن توفير الطعام
والتدفئه بل وعن دفع فواتير الايجار
واقساط القروض ايضا من حربا الجزيره لندن